Now you know what this is really useful for?
Sometimes you need to perform a computation on a really big hunk of data,
maybe so big that it won't even fit into the GPU memory.
No problem, you say. I'll break up the data into chunks that will fit on GPU memory.
I'll copy each chunk over, do my processing, and then copy each chunk back.
Then I'll do the same thing with the next chunk and so on.
And this will work fine, and it will get the job done.
But the problem is if this is a high-end GPU, it can easily have several gigabytes of memory.
And so these copy operations where you're copying several gigabytes of data,
enough to fill the GPU memory, do your processing, and then copying several gigabytes of data back,
these copy operations can end up taking a significant amount of the time
of your total computation.
You see our problem.
If this is the timeline, we spend some time copying, then we spend some time processing,
then we spend some time copying back, and the process repeats.
So here's where asynchronous copies can come to the rescue.
Instead, we can break up our data into chunks that are half the size
and we can do an asynchronous copy, filling half the GPU.
Then we can launch some kernels on the GPU to start processing that data
and immediately do another asynchronous copy, filling the rest of the GPU data,
and immediately start processing that data.
When the first chunk of data completes, we'll copy it back
and start copying the next half size chunk of data, all while this one is still completing.
So you get the idea.
We're going to copy over half the data at a time
and immediately start processing it while we copy the next half of the data.
Now the timeline looks like this.
And the important point is that we're managing to overlap data transfers and computation.